[Musique]
dupont ce nom pourrait être vannes
annecy derrière ces six lettres il n'y
avait le danseur le goût de vie libre de
vaincre de gagner la bataille de l'opéra
grâce à une sorte de folie enthousiasme
[Musique]
patrick dupond dupont ça vous dit
quelque chose
quand je rentre à l'opéra tout le monde
m'a dit il faut changer de nom c'est pas
possible un dupont l'opéra fin à dupont
qui réussit ça n'existe pas ça n'a
jamais réussi à parler du pont de tintin
et j'ai dit non pas du tout au contraire
si je suis une star et que je m'appelle
dupont c'est fantastique c'est un
paradoxe incroyable être être une star
et s'appelait dupont comme tout le monde
enfin je m'appelle pas du pont comme
tout mangé un dé à la fin tension
[Musique]
vous êtes une star je voudrais bien mais
je suis pas futur donc sur étoile à
l'opéra de paris patrick dupond graine
de star est déjà comparé aux plus grands
lourdes responsabilités lorsque l'on a
tout juste 20 ans
[Musique]
e
oh
on
patrick vous avez répété combien
d'heures aujourd'hui 18h40 je suis
arrivé à me dis pas ça fait 18h38 répète
dit fatigué je suis un peu mort oui bah
parce que chaque rapid ici on m'a
demandé un effort physique bien sorti
cherbourg alors qu'est ce qui vous fait
danser finalement ce qui a fait danser
les gens qui me demandent de danser
[Musique]
non
il a besoin d'être le premier il a
besoin d'eux il est peut-être un peu
exhibitionniste c'est vrai on lui
reproche quelquefois parce que il en
fait on fait trop il ne sait pas se
modérer mais je crois que c'est un
instinct vous savez on peut pas on peut
pas brider un cheval de course il a
envie de courir il a envie de galoper il
est très bien quand il le fait et si on
le mode air trop il n'est pas à son aise
alors patrick basset la même chose il
veut il veut être partout dans le monde
entier son ambition se limite pas à
paris il est demain chicago ill et au
japon il a envie de deux d'être connue
mondialement c'est un besoin et je
nécessaire chez lui le problème de
patrie comme beaucoup de jeunes danseurs
d'un très grand talent et surtout à
paris où les choses vont un peu trop
vite c'est un endroit de consommation ce
n'est pas un endroit de construction il
est déjà sur un supermarché au lieu
d'être encore dans une arrière boutique
d'un très très grand natale de grands
ateliers et l'opéra est à la fois un
atelier et un supermarché
c'est à dire que les nouvelles vont vite
dès qu'il y a un talent exceptionnel
tout le monde s'en empare
ils veulent utiliser et musée avant de
le construire de l'investir et de le
solidifier lundi dans ces la bayadère
mardi partait d'enfer qu'il garde
mercredi il était à paris
j'accepte justement des contrats parce
que ça me permet de lancer un petit peu
en dehors de l'opéra et issa il faut
parce que on peut pas rester non plus
tout le temps enfermé tout le temps tout
le temps tout le temps le terrain après
ça devient une espèce de routine et il
faut un artiste ne doit pas se laisser
enfermer dans l'art dans le dans le
train train quotidien ils doivent faire
des choses nouvelles il doit doit voir
des gens nouveaux
il doit vivre des expériences nouvelles
tout le temps tout le temps et justement
ça ça me permet un petit peu de me
renouveler moi mais vous ne prenez pas
la chandelle par les deux bouts de façon
non je pense pas parce que si je voulais
l'a brûlée par les deux bouts j'en ai
l'opportunité je dis que je pourrais
accepter tous les contrats comptes
propose je pourrais faire n'importe quoi
je pourrais faire des bonnes et des
mauvaises choses et là justement il ya
quand même une espèce de sélection au
départ j'essaie de de sélectionner les
choses qui sont les plus intéressantes
les plus importantes pour moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est très sérieux dans son métier il
n'y paraît pas grand chose beaucoup de
gens s'y trompent parce qu'ils aiment
bien rire et la fnac 20 ans beaucoup de
gens oublient il a des performances que
bien et danseurs beaucoup plus vieux lui
envient et on oublie qu'il n'a que 20
ans et c'est un enfant enfin moi j'étais
un enfant mais c'est un c'est un enfant
qui est très gai très sexy lloris
facilement
[Musique]
il savait un tout petit peu denses et
voulait faire des pointes et avec une
idée avait vu les pointes un jour dans
un la télévision et il croyait que les
hommes faisaient des pointes alors là je
lis un peu arrêté parce que il a été un
peu déçu sur le moment ça a été je crois
la première le premier contact qu'il a
eu avec le métier de danseur c'est à
dire qu'on allait lui faire des
restrictions qu'il n'allait pas faire
n'importe quoi que maintenant c'était
quelque chose de sérieux et il a fallu
qu'ils réfléchissent on est reparti la
du cours de max bozzoni on est revenu
que trois jours après et c'est patrick
avec la décision avait dit oui je veux
le faire
ça a démarré comme ça 2 parce que c'est
ambitieux pour sa carrière oui
d'ailleurs en ce moment il n'ya que sans
travail
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que la gloire vous attire ah oui
j'adore ça pourquoi parce que ça me je
me sens bien je me sens bien glorieux
nous émeut qu'on parle de vous ah
j'adore cela oui
dans la publicité alors un autographe
que ça représente pour vous on voit un
autographe marambaud avant c'était
c'était la consécration
maintenant la consécration soixantaine
mais disons que je me rends compte que
finalement donné un autographe c'est
donner un peu de soi même aux gens et ça
leur fait plaisir
si ça ça peut leur faire plaisir mais si
vous êtes disponible pour votre public
en revu complètement
alors maintenant comment voyez-vous
votre carrière internationale il est
célébré déjà les les demandes et de tous
les côtés on place des exigences sur son
temps sur sa personne sur et de nouveau
cette gentillesse on dit pas non alors
il brûle et on le brûle c'est quelque
chose c'est un très beau feu de joie
qu'on voudrait bien faire durer un peu
longtemps quand même que plus de gens en
profitent
[Musique]